you know you know if anything about it
is when I got in the firearms I lived in
Texas my whole life and I went what 23
years without ever shooting gun touching
a gun
and when I got into it I started the
first thing I wanted to do was shoot
competition right and so you shoot
competition you know do you do those
competitions like John wick style where
you go to three gun they call that three
gun three guns yeah so basically three
gun consists of three different platform
platforms a rifle shotgun and a handgun
so how does this competition work so
basically they just set up it's it's
basically set up various courses where
you have to utilize one of those three
platforms some of the courses you
utilize all three and so it's just it's
just your set to a timer you got to
clear the course as fast as possible oh
yeah and the clearing the course is are
you is there like walls that you have to
look I know you're it's only limited by
your imagination you ever see that [ __ ]
where Keanu Reeves was preparing for
John wick - oh you were there I wasn't
okay so I was there not for that
particular video that went viral but I
was there one day when he was training
and so I met him after the fact how is
he different spacey Spacey yeah
interesting but not in a bad way it's a
very very calm energy yeah you know why
why that's how he handles being that
famous gotcha
I just shuts off I picked up on it
immediately yeah and it wasn't it wasn't
bad it was a it wasn't a bad thing it's
a good thing yeah I realized he's the
matrix guy yeah that's some over-the-top
Fame he hit that Johnny Depp Tom Cruise
level of Fame and then just became this
super chill mellow guy that can just
like go through crowds that God goes
sits on the subway by himself know like
it's freaking awesome yeah but there's
no obvious outward displays of wealth
from him and he's insanely wealthy when
you see him he's dressed like me yeah
he's got like a regular watch on and
sneakers he's normal as [ __ ] man it's
it's real weird like he's he's figured
out a way to avoid like there he is
right there
I'm a [ __ ] subway just chilling
you know and he looks like a totally
normal dude yeah well and people freak
out they're like is that no can't be
like people ignore him because he's
figured out a way to just sort of just
layer in plain sight and then even if
you talk to him he's just normal like
everybody that I know that some Adam has
said the dudes like totally look at it
he lets his chick sit down you know he
said you want to sit down go ahead pull
him and he just stands up look it mean
even the way it's not no bodyguard